students across the valley getting ready
to get back to class yeah a couple weeks
away this year eight news now is teaming
up with las vegas honda dealers as well
as smith's groceries to help them get
equipped with the school supplies they
need before that big first day kirsten
joyce and christian cassadas are live
this afternoon at smith's up in sky
canyon with how we can help hi there
guys
hey there you two we are having some fun
out here talking to some wonderful
people who've been dropping by supplies
all day long in fact since we started
out here earlier today that's right just
a few minutes ago a family came by with
a shopping cart they dropped off maybe
about seven or eight items in this box
very happy to just give back to our
community here and there are so many
great setups at smith's they make it
really easy when you're checking out or
they have certain departments with the
school supplies so we're going to be
chatting with people throughout the next
three hours if you're home and you
thought maybe i'll go pick some dinner
up well stop on by we're at the sky
canyon smith stop by say hi we're going
to show you all the goodies that people
have been dropping off and how easy it
is for you to make a donation at any
smith's or your las vegas honda that's
right and you really can just donate any
little thing backpacks crayons pencils
we have all this information of course
on our website 8newsnow.com
we'll see you back here in about 10
minutes
brian denise all right the